you know there's a game theory has a
history of being applied to understand
and to give us hope about nuclear
weapons for example the mutually assured
destruction is a game theoretic concept
that you can formulate some people say
it's oversimplified but nevertheless
here we are and we somehow haven't blown
ourselves up do you see a future where
this kind of
this kind of system can be used to help
us make decisions geopolitical decisions
in the world
well like I said the original motivation
for the game of diplomacy was the
failures of World War One The Diplomatic
failures that led to War uh and the real
take-home message of diplomacy is that
you know if people approach diplomacy
the right way then war is ultimately
unsuccessful
um the way that I see it war is
an inherently negative sum game right
there's always a better outcome than
more for all the parties involved and my
hope is that you know as AI progresses
then maybe this technology could be used
to help people make better decisions
across the board and you know hopefully
avoid negative some outcomes like War
yeah I would look I mean I just came
back from Ukraine I'm going back there
uh on deep personal levels
think a lot about
how peace can be achieved and I'm a big
believer in conversation uh leaders
getting together and having
conversations and trying to understand
each other
yeah it's fascinating to think um
whether each one of those leaders can
run a simulation ahead of time like if
I'm an [ __ ]
what are the possible consequences if
I'm nice what are the possible
consequences
um my guess
is that if the president of the United
States got together with uh Vladimir
zielinski and Vladimir Putin that there
will be significant benefits to
um the president United States not
having an ego
of kind of
playing down of giving away a lot of
chips for the future success of a world
so giving a lot of power to the two
presidents of the competing Nations to
achieve peace
um that's my guess but it'd be nice to
run a bunch of simulations but then you
have to have human data right you really
because it's like the game of diplomacy
is fundamentally different than
geopolitics you need data you need like
I guess that's the question I have like
how transferable is this to uh like I
don't know any kind of negotiation right
like to any kind of look some local I
don't know a bunch of lawyers like
arguing like a divorce like divorce
lawyers like how transferable this all
kinds of human negotiation well I feel
like this isn't a question that's unique
to diplomacy I mean I think you look at
RL breakthroughs reinforcement learning
breakthroughs in previous games as well
like you know AI for Starcraft AI for
Atari you haven't really seen it
deployed in the real world because you
have these problems of it's really hard
to collect a lot of data
and you don't have a you don't have a
well-defined action space you don't have
a well-defined reward function these are
all things that you really need for
reinforcement learning and planning to
be really successful today now there are
some domains where you do have that
um code generation is one example
theorem proving mathematics that's
another example where you have a
well-defined action space you have a
well-defined reward function and those
are the kinds of domains where I can see
RL in the short term being incredibly
powerful but
yeah I think that those are the barriers
to deploying this at scale in the real
world but and the hope is that in the
long run we'll be able to get there
yeah but see diplomacy feels like closer
to the real world than does Starcraft
like because it's natural language right
you're operating in the space of intense
and in a space of natural language that
feels very close to the real world and
it also feels like you could get data on
that from the internet
yeah and that's why I do think that
diplomacy is taking a big step closer to
the real world than anything that's came
before in terms of game AI breakthroughs
the fact that
you know we're we're communicating in
natural language we've we're leveraging
the fact that we have this like General
data set of uh dialogue and
communication from a breadth of the
internet
um that is that is a big step in that
direction we're not 100 there but um but
we're getting closer at least